manille alors qu'alger l'interview maman
a dit aide toi regarde alors plus est ce
que votre mère vous a déjà dit ton père
et moi on va divorcer
oui est ce que votre mère vous a déjà
dit laisse tomber chanteur ça le métier
de drogués oui vous ai déjà dit oui le
monsieur un peu efféminé si c'est celui
avec lequel je vais me marier crise
non elle me l'a pas dit est ce que votre
mère vous a déjà dit je rentre en france
tu me suis oui est ce que votre mère
vous a déjà dit chris tu vas aller vivre
avec ton père non est ce que votre mère
vous a déjà dit tu compte rester à la
maison jusqu'à quel âge crise fissure
pas notre soir est ce que votre mère
vous a déjà dit crise j'ai un amant non
est ce que votre mère vous a déjà dit
qu'à des feuilles qu'on roule un pétard
ensemble qu'elles sont faits
moi c'est moi qui lui ai demandé en fait
il a pas de fuite en avant
je ne suis même pas rouler un joint
même avec une machine console qui je fus
un quartier parce que tu sais pas mais
pour tout dire danser en fait elle elle
même elle me donner leur avis et tu peux
me rouler un joint ce taux plein est ce
que le meilleur est déjà dit tu sais
crise il est gay c'est pas grave non est
ce que votre mère vous a déjà dit christ
encore oublié de m'appeler pour mon
anniversaire
oui est ce que votre mère vous a déjà
dit je suis fier de toi mon fils tu sais
non semaine non si ça va je suis dit
elle manie de toujours tous les jours
tous les jours tout et je n'en sais
attend il ya personne qui plus admiratif
et plus supporters et plus que ma mère
ça y est la plus un bisou non non non
béraud a réconciliés est ce que votre
mère vous ai déjà dit wilm envers moi je
peux plus